Don is with us in Phoenix Arizona
welcome that I've Ramsey showed on
hey thanks Dave yeah better question so
Dave I'm 45 years old
yep three hundred percent I've got two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
the bank I have one rental house
probably eighty five thousand dollars in
an IRA so my question is I've
accomplished all my goals and I'm kind
of in a limbo state I don't know where
to go from here what what do I do
I'd like to have six thousand dollars a
month coming in without working so I
could you know enjoy life but I don't
know how to get there from here okay
well I guess you'd need investments
large enough that they created six
thousand dollars in income right yeah so
that would be a goal mm-hmm okay and so
you've got 250,000 sitting in the bank
yeah Why What yeah exactly
because I I sold the business and poured
a lot of money so I've got that money
sitting there and I want to admit
invested widely but I don't want to make
you wrong decisions mm-hmm okay well I
mean the way don't nobody wants to make
wrong decisions um so we met there was
something wrong here so even though
that'd be senator interesting snows okay
I want to put this in the calculator
because I'm gonna do a little bit of
math here and try to there we go yeah so
you need like eight million dollars and
I can't be right
seventy-five you know a divide yeah you
need nine hundred thousand bucks okay so
you've got it you got two hundred fifty
thousand right yeah and and everything's
paid for everything and you don't have
any do you have any rental property or
anything that one rental who what's it
creating how much is it you're getting
it out of the noise I'm sorry thousand
dollars a month okay so
five thousand so you need 60 and so you
need about six seven hundred thousand
you got two hundred thousand I mean all
you gotta do is do a little bit of math
and say gosh if I had the money invested
at 12% for instance let's say it was me
in a mutual fund okay and just use some
rough numbers and I wanted and I knew
inflation rate was running forward and
so I didn't will pull off twelve because
I know the money would the inflation
rate would eat up my money eventually so
let's let's let grow by for every year
so that it covers inflation so if I'm
gonna make twelve I'd want to pull off
no more than eight if I'm gonna make ten
I'd want to pull off no more than six
because we want it to grow by enough to
cover for inflation did that make sense
to you yeah okay and so if I'm making
eight percent of my money and they need
$5,000 a month sixty thousand dollars a
year then that means you probably need
about seven or eight thousand bucks and
you got 250
so I mean you need another four or five
hundred thousand to get there and you'll
be there soon you've done great you're
on your way I mean you go yeah but I I'm
not sure where they go because I sold my
business so I started another business I
buy more Randle's do I just you know for
doing what are you that what are you
gonna do with your life I mean what's
your career what do you want to do with
your career so I've always been in the
pest control industry and I bought and
sold pest controls that I'm kind of
burned out on that okay what was it you
liked about it running did you like me
what do you buy like you're burned out
on what what is it you're burned down on
this is not the pest control business
it's just something about it one thing
it's just a minute for 20 years and for
some reason I've you know I find that I
love okay cool so we know if we know
that part that's good so it sounds like
you need to get in a different kind of a
business and run it and sound like
you're pretty good at running something
maybe even taking one that's broken and
fixing it and making a little money on
it
you saw that right yeah that wants to do
that some more you're good at it you
know a lot of money is on it yeah and
usually that part of it you enjoy
probably aspects of the pest control
world I don't know the regulation or the
people you're dealing with or whatever
that you don't like but think about the
kind of a business you'd like to run
that you thoroughly enjoy and it might
be something that you thought about for
years and just never thought you'd get
around to doing it and you could go do
that and make money but you know I think
what you need is some careers or some
career decisions it sounds like on what
you're going to do and and and a goal
and a reason to do those things and the
reason is you're trying to build enough
net worth that that you can live off six
thousand dollars a month right yeah and
you're not that far away I mean you're
over halfway there
250 thousand at ten percent would be two
thousand bucks a month okay mm-hmm and
you got a thousand bucks so that's three
thousand so you're halfway there do you
see what I did but I don't want to yeah
like I've thought about trying the whole
rental industry you know having rental
houses but I don't want to give get rid
of all my 250,000 that wouldn't be smart
right well it depends on what you're
going to do if you're gonna go buy
another business with some of it no it
wouldn't be smart investing some of it
in mutual funds would be okay or buying
some rentals would be okay
if you had another source of income but
if you need him in order if you were had
a career and you were making some money
to live on
you didn't need the 250 but in your case
I kind of think you might need a hundred
of it to go buy something and fix it up
and sell it for 200 right a business I'm
talking about what do you pay for what
you pay for those little pest control
businesses so I paid eighty five
thousand for one and then I built the
other one from the ground up okay so
would you sell the one you buy paid
eighty five for ended up selling that
floor 450 okay
so let's set a hundred aside and go buy
something else
that feels a little bit like that in a
good way but not a bad way meaning not
the parts are burnout on but the part
where you love running business you'll
buy you a little business and let's run
it up and sell it for a couple hundred
more
let's double your money on it you've got
the ability to that I want to keep some
of your capital freed for that and then
some of it needs to get to work and your
investments because you're trying to
build an investment portfolio that
creates six thousand dollars a month you
do have a goal you have two goals one is
to find and start and start or grow or
turnaround businesses that you like
running that's goal number one goal
number two is you need to build enough
investment portfolio to create six
thousand dollars and then investment for
a month that's 72 thousand dollars a
year that's what you said your goal was
and so sit down you know you can either
do that mutual funds or real estate or
some mix of the two I predict you won't
end up doing this the rest of your life
that six thousand won't cause you to
stop doing what it is you like doing
which is you like business so why I'm a
business nerd I love business if I
suddenly walked away from Ramsey
solutions which I'm not gonna do the
first thing I would do is go find
something to start or buy and grow I'm
constantly loved looking at other
people's businesses and seeing how they
tick and thinking about how I could make
it better and which I mean I sit around
my buddies that are running these things
and I man we just do consulting for each
other all the time
I'm just a business nerd I'm like you I
love it it's fun I'm like you know I
think businesses are high calling so go
get you some man you just you don't you
just come out this other thing you said
I don't do that anymore I don't know
what I want to do and I don't know what
I want to do is paralyze you so figure
it out let's get something to do let's
get get back to business cuz you got too
many skills to be on the sidelines no
reason for you to be on the bench